Sophie, what did you do
to the bathroom shelves? Look!
My hair's turned this weird color!
What... what beautiful hair.
Take a good look!
You mixed up everything
on the shelves and ruined the spells.
I didn't mix up anything,
I simply cleaned up.
Cleaning, always cleaning.
I told you not to get too carried away.
It's hopeless.
How humiliating.
It's not that bad.
This new shade's quite lovely.
I'm done for. What's the point
in living, if you aren't beautiful...
Stop, Howl! Cut it out!
He's calling on the spirits of Darkness.
He did this last time a girl dumped him.
Please, Howl, that's enough.
You can just dye your hair again.
I've had enough of you, Howl!
I've never once been beautiful!
I've had enough of this place!